and wouldn't you know with the best
record thus far in the gambling show it
is Adam left Co and that is the most
important part of the gambling show it's
not right Chris nope it's about money
here's your $20 thank you
before we even get into betting right I
want to let people know of the one thing
about this show that can truly be making
them money if you listen to our film
breakdown podcast I said that one of our
fans had turned $3 into a hundred
dollars into $400 and what have they
done
they have been parlaying simms --is
guaranteed to lose is that right last
week sims guaranteed to lose five and oh
the week before that five and no I wait
the week before that four and one okay
here 14 and one in your last 15
guaranteed to loose in your last 25
guaranteed to lose your twenty two and
three so if there's one thing to bet on
this show it is sims as guaranteed to
lose now I will say this for the
gamblers out there yeah they are
typically the very big favorites but
right now you are [ __ ] hitting brows
so wait wait so what is par so - so two
weeks ago yeah he put he said to win
right money line the five teams that you
picked guaranteed to win you bet him all
together he bet them all together so
they all have to hit and he turned three
dollars into a hundred dollars I don't
think he did a parlay again because he
didn't want to mess with his best but he
bet I think he bet on all your team's
again okay turned a hundred into $400
got you so right now the part of this
show that people should be listening to
is the very end so you should listen to
the entire up the time codes are in the
description just skip all the way to
guarantee to lose and that's about all
you need to hear oh that's interesting
yeah no but parlay and myself here well
I mean big team parlays especially with
big favorite parlays as never when I
would recommend ever but right now
you're guaranteed to losses are on Fuego
so when you pick a money line guaranteed
to lose
like so what I'm saying like what was
the what was the money like you're
literally gonna pick the pound bills
last week probably not a lot not a lot
no especially if you're taking money
line or a really big favorite right it's
you're paying so much more money to win
than actual gotcha but then the act of
parlaying it kind of evens it out okay
okay yeah but right now man you're on
fire with GTL dams now I got pressure on
your records now 30 and 10 remember you
start off the season like I don't like
two and three and week one yeah yeah all
right you want to do self scouting
before we do the recap from last week
sure so we got a couple messages from
some people with a self Scout for us and
this is perfect actually that you have
this year so a lot of people hit us up
in our DMS and said for a podcast that
cares and talks about the environment as
much as you do it seems a little odd
that you're constantly drinking out of
plastic cups like let go is I agree so
we we talked to our guys here bleacher
poor we'd out in order and we got some
gifts for you today so I've hidden them
over here Wow what this is next-level
crap right here whoa whoa this is
plastic needs to be erased from the
earth I don't know why we have plastic
anything like Symes and left go what are
these mugs tumblers blows did we get a
nice shot of that with Sims up at the
camera there hi my name is Chris Sims
and I'm environmental friendly and I and
I'm Adam left go and I'm only drinking
out of this because Josh gave it to me
so I'm gonna take your plastic ah the
finish yeah finish that water and then
we're gonna throw that out and we're
never gonna happen girl whoever who was
it that idea anybody said specifically
to say like to self scout us there we
had a bunch of people honestly so I
didn't even write down their names cuz a
lot of people were like wow that's a lot
of plastic cups you guys are using in
there are you ready yes I only have one
question do you have a good security
system yeah do you
I put the alarm on every night my wife
is like Kim jong-eun like it's
ridiculous I've never heard you how do
you say it how do you say that I don't I
don't know if you like gainers yeah
because I am I'm afraid I may be
stealing your thunder
for the fourth week in a row I've
completely changed the way I make
and what I've done this time is I've not
looked at the spread at all what I've
done is I've raised a few questions with
every game right and I've gone to the
statistics to see how these teams will
match up right and then what did I do
I predicted the score yeah say you like
that you know what's really interesting
right my limes weren't all matching up
but my overs and unders were almost
exact so I came out of point right the
main things that I'm gonna be focusing
on in today's show I like this are
points allowed right points scored
because I think that's actually a trend
that a lot of gamblers look at it's
indicative sure and I'm also looking at
game flow which teams typically get
outscored a lot in the second quarter
and then does it match up with the other
team scoring because I think when you've
watched teams a lot yeah first half
teams and second half teams that's the
main thing that I did right then I went
to the lines after the fact I'm stealing
your thunder but that's okay that's
that's what friends do and right so
you've doing this why cuz I've been
beatin your butt the last three weeks no
it's more of I'm tired of looking at
this gambling stuff right and I realized
it probably jumbles your brain to a
degree that and then I was like you know
what I actually feel like I know these
teams
I don't also want to look at the last
few games as an indicator of how they're
gonna be in this game right I think a
lot of things that I would do in the
show is well Seattle stop the the run
defense the last three weeks yeah that
doesn't mean you got to look at it
overall whole seas whole season and and
we have a better sample size now we did
that were eight games in that's just so
you guys know when I see there I see
who's playing I try not to I don't look
at his email like I don't I didn't look
at his email to the sky saw the two and
a half favorite when I just happened to
open up my email because it was on the
front page for the first game you know
they made preview size we may be aligned
on Gmail right but then from there I do
NFL Jesus and I look at the game and
then I just go okay and I look up the
two schedules this is the only thing I
do I go to the schedules of each team
and I just go home yeah roughly they do
this oh man this is the only complete
team they played this is the only this
team how many quality but I just kind of
look at it that way and then just go
okay this seems like a 2421 game I
filled out seven page
so I apparently looked at a little bit
more recap from last week yes alright
guys so we Kate last week Sims you made
700 bleacher bucks congratulations Wow
I can't believe I made that you made
$600 in the Green Bay Rams game
Minnesota New Orleans game New England
Buffalo game so the last three games you
you made a big chunk of your money the
gotcha let's go you made 520 bleacher
bucks congratulations and I found 800 on
those three games sweet nailed those
three games we nailed Packers which we
got a little bit lucky Saints and then
New England Thank You Devin McCourty
right well we got lucky and unlucky I
mean yes
I mean army doesn't fumble it's gonna be
they're gonna win or they're gonna lose
by two I went one in eight in one
o'clock games and Thursday Night
Football
whoa I got shellacked in the early slate
like shellacked in there early Lepke was
sitting here on Sunday looking at his
spreadsheet just going I'm gonna go one
and eight this is unbelievable how do I
even do this I'm one at hate right now
yeah the only game I got right was
Washington and I was getting nervous the
end of the house all right so looking at
the bank accounts for the whole season
loses ncinnati was [ __ ] you are in
the black my friend you are sitting at
90 bleacher bucks let's go you are still
in the negative but close you are at
minus eighty bleacher bucks on the
season and then looking at the records
overall Sims you are 58 59 and three and
left go is 57 60 and oh I'm not winning
the record race that of my original
comment I went I went three and one in
left go LOX
oh good job and you were five and oh and
guaranteed to lose way to go man I just
I made some ground the last did he get
any of the scores you guessed
32:24 on Chiefs Broncos and that was 32
23 that I was super super close yeah
everything else yeah kinda but that was
the one that was like oh he almost
nailed that one where did I pick the
Rams Bears Jets you were close
you had a 24-17 those 20 it was 24 10
they got that touched right what was
your other good what was the Rams
Packers score I pick from you said 35 31
oh so you're a little higher than high
yep all right guys let's start picking
some games
Thursday night football our scores match
up one in six Oakland Raiders on the
road visiting the one in seven San
Francisco 49er wait what what are you
doing what do you mean when I need the
first paragraph give me your [ __ ]
speech Kirk Cousins all right raise your
level can we have a 30 like a speech
what are we doing right now I there are
10,000 people out there listening right
now men but only three of us sitting
right here men only three of us sitting
right here men so we need to do it on
the field tonight men okay men all right
let's do it
that was Kirk Cousins yeah they're
cousins that's good is this because you
believe he looks like Kirk oh he looks
like that was good I didn't practice
that I just wanted to see him outside of
his comfort zone first you tell us at
10,000 smaller wait so what have you
thought about Kirk Cousins speeches this
year he needs to stop rehearsing them it
comes off as fake get out there and talk
speak from the heart that's right we're
not rehearsing any of this nothing about
curves Cousins is not prepared yeah and
it's yeah it bothers me I would like him
to just get in the middle look around at
the crowd like breeze last week bull
breezes it was angry he was angry he was
pissed and it showed right Kirk I was
like what are you reading a script yeah
finds a theme and then he goes from the
heart
yep all right anyway the one in six
Oakland Raiders on the road visiting the
one in seven San Francisco 49ers
Thursday Night Football spread in this
game is San Francisco - two and a half
and the weather tonight in Santa Clara
not San Francisco because the game is
not in San Francisco hi in Santa Clara
today is 81 low is 54 mostly sunny I
should add it's gonna be 70 degrees
today here in New York on the first day
of November
kinda weird that's why we're not using
plastic cups or invite of injuries
questionable for the Raiders Collette
CEO semele Darryl Worley Gary and Conley
TJ Clemens is out for the Niners we have
a 50-50 gametime decision again we're
doing this Thursday have CJ Beathard
out though Rubin Foster Jack whiskey
tart Anton Exim Beathard brie de Meaux
Sturt Garcon Richburg and Sherman are
all questionable gosh Dan yes I didn't
realize there were that beat
yes wolf completely holy crap Batman um
you're gonna go first okay um okay we'll
make this quick really I think the thing
that just jumps out to me in the
football game
you know the Raiders should win this
football game I do feel that I first of
all I just put it as simple as this
derrick karr greater than whoever the
[ __ ] starts a quarterback for the San
Francisco 49ers especially the other guy
Mullins yeah I'm not gonna learn his
name Southern Miss until he completes
the pass I don't learn his name I
learned that he's a 6 1 2 tenor Oh a 6 1
to touch means that when I'm watching
the game on Thursday night I'm gonna be
like oh look at this little [ __ ] running
around so we're gonna see how that good
it's gonna it's not gonna be great but
the thing that I think scares me about
the game altogether okay first of all
the Raiders come off a ugly loss over in
London that that's not gonna sit well
with anybody on that organization
through the last two weeks so I do think
you're gonna see a somewhat motivated
bunch from the Oakland Raiders the other
thing I would say the Oakland Raiders
should be able to throw the ball on the
Raider I mean on the 49ers regardless
whether those guys were healthy or not
and now they're not healthy that would
make me feel even better the only thing
that scares me in this football game is
the 49ers Russia exactly right that's
the only thing they can control the
clock and run the ball with eight and 10
and 12 yard gashes that makes Kyle
almost impossible to defend when that
starts to happen because the bootlegs
and play actions even if you know Fender
ik is playing quarterback there's gonna
be some completions there because Kyle
is just gonna dial up the perfect thing
either way I'm going $50 on the Oakland
Raiders I sat next to him close in the
first class once with my dad and I was
like the seat behind and he was across
the aisle for my dad he was wearing that
white leather jumpsuit he had it was so
cool I kept looking and talk to your dad
a lot oh yeah they were buddies I mean
again I know he there's a rumor that he
tried to hire your dad as much that's
not a rumor that's real I mean all right
we're gonna get your dad on next
Wednesday we're talking I just don't
remember the whole story we were in
Florida and he had a two-day phone
interview with Al Davis I know
my dad would lie about that to make that
up too but ah so that's it I go I think
the Raiders I think it was your 23-19
this is hilarious so I the way I did it
too is I wanted to look at questions my
first one is the Niners can run the ball
how are the Raiders doing against the
run their last in football one hundred
and forty four point seven yards per
game they've allowed to 200 yard rushing
performances this season
San Francisco six best rushing offense
who than the two to hundreds do you
member off to chop your heads I believe
one just keep going Cleveland definitely
had well right
you might be talking about one guy as a
team no no I'm saying as a team they
allowed 200 yards rushing and then I
thought you know is San Francisco
whoever's playing quarterback can
Oakland get to them
Oakland only has seven sacks the entire
season but San Francisco is second in
terms of sacks allow yeah so and I went
and look the number one team in sacks
allowed is Cleveland and when Oakland
played Cleveland they had two sacks and
it's the only game this year where
they've had more than one set that's
unbelievable
so their big game that they had a lot of
sacks was two against Cleveland so I
don't think they're gonna get a ton of
pressure on whoever's playing
quarterback Johnny san Francisco's 25th
and sacks Derek Carr is going to have
time san Francisco's 25th and past
offense Oakland's eleventh and passing I
see this game going with the 49ers set a
tone a little bit with the running game
yeah Derek Carr makes it close at
halftime
I think the Niners extend a little bit
in the third that's what I thought but I
don't know who this quarterback is yeah
I think Derek Carr I liked what they did
in the first half
I have Oakland 23 San Francisco 20
this is incredibly but it's I don't have
enough faith because also in terms of
game flow Oakland 51 point deficit in
fourth quarters but San Francisco 36
point deficit so both of them suck in
the fourth quarters yeah I just think
that Oakland has a better quarterback
right now and they edged this one out
but I'm only doing ten dollars on
Oakland because I don't want yeah barely
win baby
I'm not that confident yeah so you were
23 1923 and I would think I was going to
go 23 20 and I just said wait so in many
of my scores were round numbers I'm not
as experienced as you at this stuff
would I break it down to sometimes as I
go wait 23 20 that means that they're
gonna score two touchdowns at two field
goals and I was like I don't think they
can score two touchdowns so I think
it'll be like a field goal fest that
kind of I can see that yeah all right
guys first not gonna be fun I'm only
gonna enjoy it for the camera angles of
Gruden and Shanahan because both are
some of the most demonstrative coaches
in the NFL yes and you both know when
you're pissed and I love pissed Kyle
Shanahan it usually means like a smack
of the leg with the play sheet and it's
a lot of like are you [ __ ] kidding me
hey switch I love alright first game on
Sunday the four and three Chicago Bears
visiting the two and six Buffalo Bills
and Nathan Peterman Oh spread in this
game is Chicago - 10 it opened it - 8
and then moved up to 10 whether in
Buffalo on Sunday it's gonna be partly
cloudy 51 degrees ok so much Kyle long
is out damn I know I saw it happen at
the end of the game guy rolled up on his
leg
so no games did not practice Allen
Robinson Khalil Mack we do not know yet
I was on Wednesday on play Khalil Mac
mmm Nathan Peterman is starting Trent
Murphy didn't practice and Tremaine
Edmonds did not practice with a
concussion before you go I just want to
say that the bills in terms of score
flow yeah are averaging ten point nine
points per game that is the lowest in
the NFL by a three point eight points
per game margin to Arizona whoo that's
how bad they are on offense yeah
Nathan Peterman has become a mean before
you give your pick
yeah and your breakdown right is he as
bad as everyone is saying he is or has
he just done very poorly time to pick
sixes yes I actually think it's a
positive him playing in this game I
think he knows the offense better and
will be able to execute the offense
because he is being called the worst
quarterback of all time
well I yeah and I get that and it's
because of that overall look of what
you're saying
I mean he's he played in the Chargers
game at six
interceptions through a pick six against
the Texans he got the ball late I think
he threw another pick in that game so
all of that yes he's scary I'm not
trying to say he's good anything like
that I'm saying I think he can be better
than Derrick Anderson cuz he knows the
offense and they have more at his
disposal because of that has nothing
pretty to say my big thing would be this
and this is where I would go with this
you know hey the Bears on offense you
know that's a dangerous offense they
rely on the big play a little bit too
much to me my thing I would fight back
there is goes the bills aren't gonna let
up a big play
you know Jermaine Edmonds plays that
will be nice because he is a praying
mantis in the middle of the defense who
has such a presence and scares you from
making certain throws and things because
of his athleticism and size I've been
ultra ultra impressed by him I think
he's actually been better than Rokon
Smith in Chicago just so you guys know
that ah but I don't think the Bears will
be able to make big plays against the
bills
I think the Bears will be forced to
execute I would say that would be the
weakness of Mitchell troub risky's game
to this point
can he execute drives eight and ten
plays against the bills I think that's
gonna be iffy at times also I don't know
if he'll be able to run around against
the bills either the bills with that
zone defense you're he's gotta remember
right let's go all your eyes are on the
quarterback so all the eyes are there so
yes they'll be able to rally this is
gonna be our best betting show we've
ever done because what I'm looking up is
complimenting you I'm just giving I'm
calling a shot right okay got it
I like to hear that so that to me is
another negative for the the Bears at
least but I think at the end of the day
come on the Bears defense is real I have
a hard time thinking the bills could do
a whole lot there and the only way to me
that this game gets messed up is true
Biscay messes it up he throws pick sixes
or tries to scramble too much and
fumbles those type of things it's a
little scary it's in dildo ville and
that always scares me okay dildo bill is
scary and okay I'm going only $50 on the
Bears okay I picked the game
brah me take down dog aah aah
I picked the game to be 2210 I think
it'll be ugly victory for the Bears I am
seeing the same game as you yes this is
what scares me about the Bears on the
road yeah that game against Green Bay
the dud against Arizona that they barely
won right and the the the mess up fest
against Miami yes so they're not on the
road and true Biscay on the road is not
the same as Travis key at home No now
for some of your points can Buffalo run
on the Bears defense probably not Bears
third ranked run defense there's just
not enough creativity I think they don't
they shot their wad with all their trick
plays and the front quarter against the
Patriot right can sure Biscay run on the
Buffalo defense
deshaun Watson ran for two yards against
them there yeah Marcus Mariota ran for
10 yards against there you go I don't
think he's gonna have that much success
and if there's one defensive coordinator
or defensive mind that I trust as to
diagnosing what Chicago's gonna do yeah
it's Sean McDermott yeah can the Bears
pass against the bills Bears passing
offense is 21st the the Buffalo Bills
passing defense is sixth I don't see
that happening either they're gonna have
to work their way down the field yeah
they're gonna need a Benjamin long
touchdown but I wrote this in my notes
Gabriel
long time I am NOT betting on a team
that's starting Nathan Peterman I'm just
not yeah as much as I think that this
could be iffy I'm not doing it I am
picking the Bears to win 19 to 6 and I'm
putting $30 off $30 so I I look at it
and I go I've seen this Buffalo Bills
story before yeah and I know they're
coming on a short week and I know that
Nathan Peterman's there and I know their
offensive line stinks and I know that
the Bears like you know what I'm afraid
of that this is gonna be the Saints
Bills game from last year where we miss
it and they put up like 250 yards of
rough I just don't see that happening
this Bills defense I don't either
I don't I know it would have to be an
avalanche of just stupidness by Nathan
Peterman I wanted to put a lot of money
on the Bears I just I don't trust the
Bears of the 10 point spread they're not
that kind of a team I agree
look I if I if I like you had
Oh some money last week on bears - seven
against the Jets yeah even that wasn't
out and and Sam darn 'old really didn't
do anything the entire game you're just
relying on these huge Tirico and runs
that I don't think are gonna happen
again they don't do that next game on
the one o'clock slate for Sunday the
three and for Tampa Bay Buccaneers on
the road visiting the five and to
Carolina Panthers spread in this game is
Carolina - six it opened at five and a
half and whether in Charlotte on Sunday
let's check that out
it is gonna be a high of 65 a low of 51
mostly sunny left go take it away
alright so Tampa did not practice Mike
Evans and Jason pierre-paul Mike Evans
on that last try yeah what he did was an
on I was watching he's on my fantasy
team but I he it was like a non-contact
put his knee into the ground and was
just kicking it out and stopped we don't
know the extent okay like we really
don't know but believe me I'm very
worried about it right limited in
practice Gerald McCoy and Vinny curry
yeah they've missed the last two games
they're starting to practice now again
it's a calf for McCoy and an ankle for
curry did not practice for Carolina
Torrey Smith and I would say it doesn't
matter they're probably going that's all
right we got this DJ more kid we'd like
him to get more reps Samuel Wright um
and I'm gonna give you one betting
sprinkle before you go sure Carolina is
eight and two in their last ten against
Tampa Bay but in their last four games
against the NFC South they have not
covered huh so sometimes their games
against the NFC South are a little bit
closer
remember they lost that game to Atlanta
earlier this year yes
take it away soon yeah I could see that
I mean you know you get used to that
Carolina scheme you know and that's what
happens I do think the Bucs will be able
to move the ball on the Carolina
Panthers that's the first thing I'll say
of course they're gonna be able to throw
a little you know the Bucs can protect
pretty good and we just talked about the
weapons even if Mike Evans is not out
there it's not a game changer to me to
where I go oh well now they're not there
pass game screwed I don't look at it
like that I think again even though they
might throw four yards though this would
be my issue with it yeah they might move
the ball up and down the field can they
score touchdowns against Carolina
Panthers that's where I would push back
and I would say no I don't think so
negative ghostrider
that will not happen so I look at that
and that's a big thing to me playing in
Carolina is a little like Buffalo where
you underestimate it being there you
just go well it's not that hard of the
place to play and I don't know what it
is it's almost like a mental trap going
there I always found it that way even
when I played for the Bucks I got
someone message us and say that they
think that you're under raiding Carolina
Stadium well okay that's fine I mean you
know I was there a lot of Sundays and
everybody was watching NASCAR and there
was nobody there at the game yep and the
Carolina Panthers were like a playoff
caliber team so you know maybe it's
changed a little bit
it is the Cam Newton era and he has
built a culture down there so I could be
wrong about that to a degree too
I just think the mindset of players is
going they're not going in there going
oh gosh we got to play Carolina yeah
it's a cool stadium - I'm not trying to
take away from the stadium it's nice the
other thing I just look at is this hey
it's the Bucs okay the defense I mean
what what do you want me to talk about
with that defense there's nothing to
talk about
this this Panthers offense has it all
they have it all and they can do
whatever they want I think they will be
able to run the ball on Tampa I don't
care if McCoy plays and Vinny curry
plays either because they're not gonna
get 100 questions yeah they're not gonna
be a hundred percent but those kind of
injuries those are horrible injuries to
have it those positions have some ankles
yeah you get all the power the agility
your ground all that stuff that's why
you haven't seen Khalil Mack worth a
damn before you know he had to finally
sit out so those things play into my my
mind as well and then I do think a lot
of this Panthers offense and what they
can do as far as they're rolling Cam
Newton's rolling I think some of these
young weapons have found their niche
within the offense and because of that
I'm going $300 on the Carolina Panthers
what was your I picked the Panthers to
win 30 to 20 30 to 20 and I almost went
a hair stronger cuz I don't necessarily
trust a Fitzpatrick in this type of a
game either and you're gonna see in my
bets the same thing really quick I just
looked this up in terms of your red zone
question yes
Tampa Bay right now is 13th in the NFL
and red zone office in terms of getting
points on the board
guess what Carolina's red zone defenses
gosh let me just hope there's a nice
guess I mean I would think it's very
good 31st is it really remember when
Atlanta went four for four against him
in the register since he went two for
two on them in the red zone last week
Baltimore went two for two Alex Collins
getting in there huh
Balt Carolina's not a bend but don't
break Carolina is sort of like op you or
you get the ball train over yeah so the
first thing I think first thing I
wondered was can the buck stop the
Panthers running offense and I was very
pleasantly surprised that Tampa Bay's
run defenses 10th but the thing is is I
think people are just choosing to pass
on them I think that is really what the
Gary valid point yes Tampa Bay is not
running on Carolina now Tampa Bay has no
running game and I think that when you
play this Carolina zone defense they
play mainly zone right yes Carolina
plays mainly zone they're playing a hair
more man this year I would beg them
right to not play man at all yeah
because I believe that this is the one
team that if you play man against yeah
you're screwed right so I look at
Carolina and go if they sit in zone with
all these matchups I don't think Ryan
Fitzpatrick is gonna be able to pick
apart the zone but if they play man with
the Mike Evans and the OJ Howard's and
the Godwin's that's when I get concerned
huh I started looking at the game flow
yeah and I'm looking at how do they
typically do Carolina out scores their
opponents one of them they do really
well in second and fourth quarters right
so they start off a little slow and they
come in the end a half well right Tampa
Bay is tragic in second quarters they're
being outscored by 41 points they've
allowed a hundred and six points in
second quarters thus far this year
they're the only team that I've seen
that's allowed over a hundred points in
a quarter
yeah all this season right so the my
game flow is I think this is going in a
half time at twenty four to seven
Caroline I got you I think Carolina hits
there things you got a little bit of DJ
when we show that right my final score
is Carolina 3421 I almost went there I
told you I own this one thirty but I'm
only putting a hundred dollars on
Caroline right
I'm afraid of Ryan Fitzpatrick yeah I'm
afraid of late rally
now now Carolina does really well in
fourth quarters out scoring opponents by
twenty nine but I could just see those
late rallies and there's something about
when I read that statistic about the NFC
South and the familiarity and also you
know Carolina has been kind of cruising
lately yeah and and I don't like betting
on a team that whatever and I'm
wondering if the Bucks are gonna get a
charge from Ryan Fitzpatrick so I'm
putting a hundred dollars on it right
I'm confident right but something's kind
of scaring me from pulling me back yeah
I hear you that and the only thing I'll
say and I wanted to say this to what
you're talking about Carolina has been
cruising lately and I thought man would
this be kind of a letdown leak week
where they don't play their best
football right the only thing I'll say
to this is they have something dangling
in front of them the Saints are there
and I think they look at themselves as a
team that we could still win this
division and we're not gonna fall asleep
at the wheel to where it keeps them
motivated on top of their game what's
good well alright so your score was what
their I went thirty to twenty and I went
3421 yes alright let go I like you
revolutionized the strategy today do you
like it yeah I dig it you're wearing the
hoodie I just I feel good about what's
going on in here today yeah because what
I don't feel too good about him I don't
want him to win too much fun well when I
started I guess what I kind of look I'm
talking about it like it's an acceptance
speech like I have no idea if these bets
are gonna be right I was just like why
am I looking at trends yes I've been
that's you know I've made fun of you for
that before
alright guys next game at one o'clock
the seven and one Kansas City Chiefs on
the road visiting the two five and one
Cleveland Browns spread in this game is
Kansas City minus eight and a half
whether in Cleveland on Sunday partly
cloudy 57 is the high 48 is the low
Kansas City did not practice
Anthony Hitchens Frank Zombo Mitch Morse
Justin Houston Eric
a lot of those are we haven't seen much
more suggesting Barry in four weeks
Cleveland Rashad Higgins didn't practice
Jacy Treader didn't practice Joe
Schobert and damarious Randall again
Schubert Randall and shredder we haven't
really seen lately and Kansas City is
putting up thirty six point three points
per game which is incredible yeah I was
a little shocked at this line but we'll
get to it go do you want me to go first
this time
no no you go okay either way it's a I
mean I had no idea I mean yeah I was a
little surprised too not gonna lie I'm
not gonna when you fire your coach and
your offensive exactly right yeah we how
are you less of an underdog I know that
it's in Cleveland but how is how are the
Cleveland Browns with a rookie
quarterback with the out a coach and out
an offensive coordinator les underdogs
in Denver a little bit of like I always
think a little bit of the same thing
would be just every one for the Gipper
well I was also only one place charged
at home their home and I think teams go
in there going this ain't gonna be that
hard it's Cleveland there's nothing you
look at home yeah I mean they did get
blown out by the Chargers but they beat
the Ravens they beat the Jets and they
tied the Steelers all right go for it
yeah so I think okay my big point would
be Browns the Browns defense just cannot
stop all around good offenses
well-rounded offenses and then we know
this is the most well-rounded offense in
the sport really if Kansas City wants to
run the ball they could be than one of
the best run teams in football too but
[ __ ] why run it when you can throw for
30 yards on every frickin throw so
that's what it really comes down to I
don't think the Browns can stop the big
play you know I think this is a week
where Greg Williams creativity and
things he does can really come back to
screw him and I'm gonna be interested to
see maybe if he dials it back a little
weight this week and goes like okay
we're just gonna play bland normal
coverages either way so that's the only
thing I look at I just have a hard time
thinking this Browns defense at any
point can really stop this chief's
office you know I don't know if there is
a defense that exists that can stop the
Chiefs right now I I think you have to
almost out score them and they put the
pressure on you the only thing that
scare
me at all in this matchup his of course
the Browns run game you know and you
said was as idlers hurt or is a Treader
Treader so you know it's not a game
changer for me but this Browns run
offense and this offensive line like
we've been saying through training camp
it's it's a pretty good group and Nick
job is he's a player he's better than I
gave him credit for coming out of
Georgia that tells you again you got to
be careful about guys who tear their ACL
in college and what happened say that
him and girly kind of both got me that
way a little bit so I look at that but I
also look at it like this too you know
yea the Chiefs defense stinks I know
that also I don't think it's as horrible
as everybody thinks and the statistics
say because once again the Chiefs when
they pie teams they go man we got to
push the envelope this team is gonna
score points in us so we have to dial up
plays that we would not normally not
even dial up but I don't think you're
there's anything really scary about the
Browns past game I think that's what I
come back to more times than not and
because of that I think the Chiefs will
be able to put a few more people into
the run stopping game effort and there's
just too much going on in Cleveland this
week I agree I don't see it as a like
hey guys might be like oh I'm so glad he
was out of here but that doesn't mean
you're gonna play better they're gonna
feel better but it doesn't mean they're
gonna play better so because of that I'm
going $300 on the Kansas City Chiefs
dingey what the hell was that and that
was a bone arrow oh I like it do it
again
yep nice job Nick no I thought it was a
pull back release and then the sound of
doing one more time that's a no listen
to me listen to me and then listen to
this it's the arrows already in there
right it pulls it back then it's the
sound of the release and then it hits
the target yeah I guess you're right I
guess you're right I wanted more Legolas
Lord of the Rings pulling it back that's
who I pictured myself was your score
that's who I picture myself being in
Lord of the Rings okay I would be the
guy
that would be the Sharpshooter with the
era okay I would be the the really hairy
guy with the mallet in gold or I just
combined I think the Chiefs to win 3421
yeah you stole my Carolina score okay so
I want to remind everybody that the
Chiefs offense one of the greatest
things were ever seen is facing the
twenty sixth ranked pass defense and the
twenty eighth ranked run defense that's
first and foremost now the one thing
Cleveland does really well takeaways
number one in the NFL and takeaways
which is more embarrassing that they're
not winning games like if you're number
one and takeaways and you're still not
doing anything with it it's bad yeah
can the Browns take advantage of the
Chiefs 25th ranked run defense six of
their of their eight games they've had
over a hundred yards rushing that's
definitely the issue that I have there
can the Browns keep the Chiefs off the
field
Chiefs defense very famously fifth in
the NFL on third down defense the Browns
offense on third down 30th yeah they get
off the field
Patrick mahomes is gonna get a lot of
chances here I even got a little excited
yeah
how has Andy Reid fared against a Greg
Williams defense I'm curious yeah last
time they faced when Andy Reid was in
Kansas City they faced the st. Louis
Rams
when Greg Williams was there 34 to 7 you
then have to go back to 2009 and this is
when Greg Williams had a run with the
Washington Redskins yeah he only put 22
on him but his quarterback was Kevin
Cobb so I don't really care that right I
watched him Redskins defense was good it
was good hung up 33 and 12 27 21 kind of
all over the place but he's got a pretty
good record against Wright but the main
thing that I looked at was in terms of
game flow yeah
the Kansas City Chiefs in the first
quarter are tripling up their opponents
they are flying out the gates the
Cleveland Browns in all of their first
quarters combined this season have
scored 14 points Wow so in eight games
yeah they have 14 point they're just not
getting off the ground
Chiefs get on them early they're also
the Browns are bad in the second quarter
and they finish strong but I don't think
it's gonna matter I have this one Chiefs
37 to 20 and I am putting $200 on the
Kansas City Chiefs so what'd you do last
game mode you let got the sharp arrow
that I think is moving with you want my
score or my money yeah what was your
money on the game if I did a hundred on
Caroline Wright and I'm doing 200 on
Kansas okay okay I'm really I'm only
afraid of the game being in Cleveland I
don't and and I don't think that
Cleveland is this magical place and I I
don't think it's gonna have the same
thing as Baltimore and I don't think
they're gonna be a win me win one for
the Gipper it's it's a little bit of a
big line and I don't like betting huge
on big favorites anymore it kind of
scares me but yeah I just this is a this
is a great team against a team that's
falling apart before ours with a rookie
quarterback yeah I think and yeah and
then you look at Cleveland like people
usually go there oh it's a little cold
it's when you look and said he plays in
the same thing I don't think it's gonna
matter I think they're gonna be used to
those elements so before we move on did
you see left go trying to show us up
with his pen this week oh I said I was
gonna make a comment early on I stole
this from Woody's wedding is that right
yeah thing so at the end of Woody's
wedding they were like and you guys can
take anything you want from all over and
me and my girlfriend were like I really
like the pen snow it's an aesthetic pen
it looks good doesn't write what doesn't
write are you glide that it's a little
rough on the page I finally went to my
second uni-ball I got a fresh pack in my
desk no I'm good you had these not gold
- isn't that gold no this is coppers oh
I got you yeah okay next game here on
the schedule guys jets at dolphins did
you want to say something before I hey I
was gonna say are you liking the
information I'm bringing this week I do
yes very much
I always like your information this is
just more useful it is more yeah a lot
of left go sprinkles all right
the three and five New York Jets on the
road visiting the four and four Miami
Dolphins spread in this game is Miami
minus three and the weather in Florida
on Sunday high of 83 low of 77
thunderstorms in the morning 80%
humidity
keep that in mind northeast team heading
down to humid South Florida and I'm
gonna I literally wrote down next to my
notes you know who's gonna love this
heat Arnold you're right Sam Darnell's
probably like I played in Chicago last
week with sleeves I am thrilled to be
down there in Miami right uh all right
Odell Beckham traded know it was Ravens
defensive coordinator takes jab at levy
on well what do you say there are a lot
of stats that the Steelers are better
without him might be why he's riding a
jet ski down in Miami from wing damn
Robbie Anderson a noon watch remain
Johnson did not practice for Miami Kenny
Stills didn't practice the only thing
I'm gonna add is the Dolphins are only
scoring twenty one point eight points
per game just an interesting little
nugget their jets are or their average
scores 24 to 25 yeah one other betting
nugget yeah the Jets have lost nine of
their last ten road games
damn damn that's unreal yeah I feel like
a win was against Miami in Miami for
some reason but I don't know that I just
know that the last Jets Miami game
completely clouded my mind and I'm I'm
liking the Jets here yeah alright so
that yeah let's start there I mean first
of all I do think the Jets should be
able to run the football that's the
first thing I look at what I watch the
Jets I go can they run the football
because it is a rookie quarterback their
offensive passing game is not anything
spectacular at this point so I always
base everything can they run it what's
better right I'm asking you guys yeah if
I have a statistic to answer his
question do I do it or do I save it for
myself I like when you save it okay so
you all at once yeah okay so um yes so I
do think they're gonna be able to run
the ball against the Dolphins but
there's just not enough big people in
the middle of the Dolphins defense I
mean we talked about it a little bit
when I know we broke down the Houston
Texans game the Dolphins don't have run
stopping linebackers McMillan ray Crowe
Quan McMillan is the only guy there that
can really play that type of football
Kiko Alonso as a space guys better for
the pass game does all of that same with
Jerome breaker that cookie from Ohio
State he's a space guy an athlete and
with the lack of big people and in my
didn't Taylor get hurt am i who am i
wrong with that yeah I don't doesn't
matter cuz they have lack of big people
either way but I thought 96 Vincent
Taylor got hurt okay so either way it
doesn't matter that that's a problem
sometimes when these guys get hurt my
wish there was like a running injury
report it's like oh by the way this
guy's been out for five weeks yeah
sometimes they only update you on like
the meat that guys are kind of hurt okay
yeah I don't know why I thought he got
hurt in the game either way but it
doesn't really affect me at all it
doesn't affect me at all
I respect the Jets defense I really do
the Jets defense is good they can stop
the run they got plenty of big people
their only issue is pass rush and to me
one of their biggest flaws as we talked
in the film breakdown is - they
overcompensate for that sometimes and
they blitz too much but the Miami
Dolphins is not are not impressive on
offense it's too simple I don't know any
other way to say it when I watch their
drop back Pass game I am underwhelmed on
a weekly basis yeah they got some
explosive players here and there but I
think this is a type of offense that
Todd Bowles will be all over as far as
the schemes dropping people in the zones
all those were in Week three yes I know
they won they were the way better team
remember we talked about it they
outplayed them they had the one Kenyan
Drake play the interception yeah bumble
exactly so I look at this I think this
will be a close game Brock Osweiler I'll
give him a little credit I do think the
last three weeks he's thrown the ball
about as good as I've ever seen him
throw it now that's really good for
Brock Osweiler it's not like knocking my
socks off compared to the rest of the
NFL I am going $50 on the New York Jets
yes I am I'm picking the game to be 24
to 20 Jets win down there in Miami can
the Jets run the dolphins dolphins run
defense 29th in the NFL I'd say that's a
yes well my big question was is either
team gonna get to the quarterback right
Miami has 11 sacks all year 30th and the
NFL Jets have 17 23rd Brock is going to
have time and the one thing that I
always hear from Jets fans is their
secondary is completely banged up Buster
screens not what he was and there's
gonna be some options and the thing
about Brock is I look at it and I go
Devante Parker does that continue Kenyan
Drake how do they get him open yeah so I
do worry about that with Jeremy's pass
off adjustment worries Miami has 10 days
to prepare yeah 10 days to rest jets are
super banged up yeah I factored that
into Miami is 3 in 1 at home jets are 1
in 3 away yeah and then let's talk about
game flow ok Jets get their ass kicked
in the first quarter of most games
second quarter they come back that's
alright oh I think this games going to
start I think the Dolphins jump out to
an early lead but the Jets make it
somewhat close at halftime the
difference is that Dolphins fall apart
in second half's of games they are being
outscored by 52 points in the second
half of games it worn down the Jets they
kind of hang around they hang around big
people I am putting $10 on the Jets
[Applause]
and I have the Jets winning this game 26
to 24 yeah that's how I see it
I just don't want to put a ton of money
on this game I don't ever go lower than
50 so hey Mike yeah mine is I'm looking
at this game and I don't really trust
either team right I just think the Jets
were the better team before and I like
their defense their defense a lot more
yeah and I don't have a ton of faith in
Brock Osweiler because even that last
game where they put 31 on Chicago two of
them were Albert Wilson or was it Kenny
Stills Albert Wilson long runs and
Chicago mistakes and I think that the
Jets the one thing they do is they don't
make a ton of mistakes they don't all
right guys next game here at one o'clock
the for two and one even greater games
on the road visiting the four and for
Baltimore Ravens spread in this game is
Baltimore minus three weather in
Baltimore on Sunday 59 degrees is the
high and it will be sunny left go take
it away pittsburgh still relatively
healthy after their bye week two weeks
ago bud Dupree missed practice with an
illness but it doesn't sound to be too
serious okay eight players missed for
Baltimore three offensive lineman and
Ronnie Stanley yeah Ronnie Stanley was
in he was out he was in he was out right
and CJ Mosley right missed practice with
a thigh in terms of scoring Steelers are
putting up twenty nine point one points
per game which is up towards the top of
the league Ravens are only allowing 17.1
points per game this season which is one
of the best in football Journal yeah and
the only thing I'm gonna say is momentum
wise Pittsburgh is playing for something
the tragedy that happened at the
synagogue I know that we would we all of
our thoughts and prayers go to people
there and it's kind of disturbing and
disgusting what we're going for but I do
think that Pittsburgh is playing for
something in that regard yeah I think
that's in the minds I think you know I
didn't even think of that but that's a
very good point for sure it is that will
be something that can unite a team in a
city and everything and do that there's
a little bit more important than levy on
bail yes it is yeah I mean hey the
Steelers they do have it going okay
that's I think the first thing we go
on both sides of the ball it's been
better and you know I know they haven't
played great teams right we know that
okay yeah you know their last three wins
it's the brand's the bangles it's the
Falcons but the bangles and Falcons have
weapons on the offensive side of the
ball the Steelers have found the right
mix of playing zones their fronts
playing better
they make them you know they pipe man in
the right situations those are the
things I like the offense is rolling too
but the offense I will say this has been
playing [ __ ] defenses so I'm still not
going like oh this Steelers offense it's
back all the way right I don't think
it's quite as creative as yours past I
don't but they are blocking well up
front and they are rolling and they have
momentum
the Ravens right now I don't know what
to think of the Ravens I know their
defense is good I get that that's not
what I'm worried about I'm worried about
the offense overall Ken Flacco make
plays in the pass game I don't think
they're gonna be able to run the ball
all that effectively against the
Pittsburgh Steelers defense and I don't
even know what Steelers ranked on that
that department I'll tell you but I just
don't trust them they scare me
but what also scares me is the Ravens
are at home and the Ravens have finally
hit desperation mode so that is what
bothers me I am going $50 on this the
pittsburgh steelers i am going to do $50
on the pittsburgh steelers i am picking
pittsburgh to win the game 23 to 20
i don't know why i'm not so this is to
me would be a stay away from this bet I
just feel like the Steelers in my eyes
are a better football team that feed off
a momentum and I just trust Ben
Roethlisberger and a B and company and
juju to make a pie or two to win the
game and all said and done Baltimore is
2 & 1 at home you picked the Ravens
there they haven't played a bad game at
home Pittsburgh is 200 and 1 on the road
I went back and looked last eight years
Pittsburgh and Baltimore have split the
season series five times which makes me
a little bit more comfortable if I want
to lean Pittsburgh yeah neither team
should have success running the ball
neither team should both run defenses
are really really good can the Steelers
pass on the Ravens I don't know man
at the second-best pass offense but the
Ravens get the second best pass defense
it's gonna be tough yeah can the Ravens
pass on the Steelers Ravens for the
eighth best passed offense in the NFL in
the Steelers pass defense is 24th I
think they could have success yeah these
are the top two teams in the NFL in
sacks
Baltimore's got 27 Pittsburgh's got 24
one of these teams is banged up on their
offensive line yes and that's Baltimore
and I think that's a huge factor in this
game yeah Pittsburgh's they got their
unit Oh what do you know there's Gilbert
Oh what do you know there is Villanueva
like it's the same guys like that's the
incredible thing about Pittsburgh their
offensive line never gets credit and
they're always the same guys and they're
always healthy yeah the game flow of
this one should be wild okay Baltimore
dominates first quarters mmm Pittsburgh
is being outscored by thirty six point
in first quarters that's Baltimore's
gonna jump out to like a 10 nothing lead
right Pittsburgh out scores teams in the
second quarter by 74 points Wow
incredible that is so it's gonna be it's
gonna be tight at halftime and
Pittsburgh's gonna come roaring back
right the third quarter Baltimore is
outscoring their opponents in the third
quarter this year so out of halftime 51
to 9 Wow right yeah and that includes
the Carolina game so I think Baltimore
jumps up I have this game Pittsburgh
wins 24 23 is the score I have so I'm
putting $200 on Pittsburgh you're saying
stay away I can't because I think that
Pittsburgh is the better team I think if
it ends up being a dogfight sure I trust
their playmakers I think that this is a
juju game I don't think this is a big
Antonio Brown game I don't think this is
a big James Connor game I think this is
juju in the slot making a man miss or
two and taking it deep right I don't
have faith in the will east needs
I'm afraid of John Brown like I'm very
afraid of John Brown he got four up
Pittsburgh last time but I think that in
an AFC North battle when you've already
lost and you kind of got embarrassed on
national television
I think Pittsburgh
into Baltimore and nudges them out and
I'm getting three points for the team
that I think is gonna win the game yes
I'm putting $200 on it okay
24 23 24 23 okay like I don't know if
you do this I like try and watch the
game of my head right and I see
Baltimore jump out and then I see
Pittsburgh score some touchdowns and
then I see him come out of halftime and
you know like I that's how I'm coming
out of my scores okay oh that's cool
that's the one however you get get to it
I don't do that I kind of just look at
the overall season the scores okay the
oh they scored big points in this game
well that defense sucks so I'm gonna
kind of cancel that one out let me get
to a team that's a little more like that
different and our scores are so that
that's that's kind of how I do it so
yeah it is actually also interesting
what you said about the the Ravens pass
offense in general that it's then I know
I would think it's feasted on the poor a
little bit I think you're probably right
a little issue there yeah yeah all right
guys next game on the one o'clock slate
for Sunday the 3 & 4 Detroit Lions on
the road visiting the 4 3 & 1
Minnesota Vikings spread in this game is
Minnesota minus 5 I know the Vikings
play indoors but just in case anyone was
curious 45 is the high in Minnesota on
Sunday it's gonna be raining in the
morning so teams will be leaving the
hotels in the rain in the clouds left go
over to you
alright so limited practice Ezekiel anza
Taylor Decker and TJ Lang yeah I don't
know when we're gonna get Zika lon
seriously it's unbelievable
in terms of Minnesota they got a bunch
did not practice on Wednesday Stefon
Diggs his ribs
Anthony bar another DN p.m. that was
kind of an issue you saw camara all over
the place without bar out there limited
in practice Dalvin cook Riley Reef
Linville Joseph Xavier Rhodes answers
and dae-ho yeah so they're all kind of a
little banged up and I got one little
betting nugget yeah liens against the
NFC North are six and one in their last
seven so they've been doing really well
in their own division as of late
interesting that's an interesting thing
too I'm just very curious I know that
they want to get Kenny Galilei out there
more but I'm just wondering what the
emotional impact of losing
Golden Tate is yeah III agree I think
that is a kind of a fascinating thing to
think about and it played a decision
into my picking of the game it really
did it really core it did it did because
okay well I'll start like this you know
Ken the Vikings run the ball it's not
one of the you know of course they're
not one of the best running running
teams in football we know all that but I
will say this it's kind of come alive a
little bit lately and I do think last
week they even showed some glimmers too
but then they got behind and they
couldn't really run the ball and
continue to do that you know I think
having L flying back in the lineup and
doing all that is great for the
Minnesota Vikings of course we know the
issues with the Lions defensive line and
all that you know the Lions will have to
be careful they can't just like go oh
we're gonna play bear front and stop the
run you can't leave your guys one-on-one
with this pass offense too much I mean
these guys are good receivers and you
play one-on-one against stealing and
digs Kirk Cousins despite all the
freaking haters out there is playing
unbelievable football but I look at the
run game as being a key to the game for
the Vikings they don't need to have to
blow the doors out they just got to keep
them honest and do it enough to where
they make the Lions play some defenses
as they go damn we can't just totally
abandon our run defense we have to worry
about that um hey the Vikings D they got
Everson Griffin back you got to look out
for that the Vikings defense pretty damn
good against the run they really are
they're better than in years past in my
in my eyes as far as stopping the run on
a more consistent basis and I also look
at you know winning in Minnesota is
tough but the biggest thing is what you
started out with I think the one less
weapon for the Detroit Lions is a big
thing I do I don't look at this offense
as being just an automatic steamroll
session you know as far as just
consistency all game long and Xavier
Rhodes we'll see if he plays either way
I still think they got a good enough
good cover guys they don't live in
man-to-man as it is and being in
Minnesota without a Golden Tate who's a
playmaker and a guy you have to worry
about not only just his physical ability
but some of the schematically
can do with him that might make you play
a different defense I think that's being
lost in the shuffle here so because of
that uh I'm going $100 on the Minnesota
Vikings okay and I'll tell you I I
originally picked the Vikings to win
this game 2820 for it Josh will tell you
that I originally picked that and I
originally put money on the liens and
then I started to write my notes and I
just said uh some of those factors a
little bit of the resurgence of the run
game if I could give you one homework
assignment starting at this moment yeah
I want to know his record from now on
when he switches his bed okay I want to
see because I think you'll be good for
you too yeah like if you find out you've
gotten every single one you've switched
wrong yeah I think that's interesting
now I would like to know too you know so
from now adding the big bets that I did
this week - I actually would like you to
add in those big bets what do you mean
well I didn't really change them but I'm
more curious when you switch a bet right
I want to know what your record is going
forward yeah I would like to know - I
actually thought about that too because
I I want well what happened to me and
this one is I've always said this we
need to start keeping track of what are
our records from betting on certain
teams like are you betting against
Kansas City yeah like you should know by
the way you've gotten that wrong seven
weeks in a row like I just think that's
good for us but finisher I got a right
Lassie yeah yeah but you but but yes III
yes I originally had it 28 24 in the
lines covering the scrunt spread but I
think the thing that changed my mind
more than anything I thought about the
Ryan Lions run defense and then I just
looked at you know okay they didn't run
the ball great against the Saints last
week you know but the Jets there was a
few plays the Cardinals there was a few
plays I do think they have it going and
have found the right formula for what
works for them so then I changed my
score from 28 24 to 31 24 and went $100
and I originally had $50 so yeah alright
so to answer your question can Minnesota
run the ball in Detroit Detroit 31st
ranked run defense Minnesota 29th reign
to run offense the big question I wrote
down will the Lions correctly run the
perfect bear front
the we'll see I don't know yeah both
teams embarrassed on Sunday Detroit to
Seattle Minnesota to New Orleans didn't
go off well one thing that scares me
yeah for your Minnesota Vikings pitch
yeah right
Minnesota has allowed the third most
plays of 40 yards or more this year and
the third most plays of 20 yards or more
thirty two plays of twenty yards or more
eight plays of forty yards or more and I
think about this Lions offense and I
think about Marvin Jones and I think
about Kenny gala day that's what they
tried to do okay so one thing let's just
buy and I don't even know this I don't
know this I would wonder I feel like it
was early in the year that's my only
thing I would push back against that
stat right when I look at their schedule
just as a whole I go 49ers they
definitely up a big bat big place the
Packers they did the Rams they did you
know I don't think they did against your
Eagles a whole lot I don't know I'd have
to sit there and look the Cardinals know
so I just I'm interested in that that's
all I was saying food for thought and I
would say that you know if I'm not the I
think the Lions offense is more closer
to those better offense here Arizona
Cardinals with Matt Stafford sure but
then I looked up Stafford versus Zimmer
right because I want to know does immer
have a read on Matt Stafford he's faced
him eight times yeah the Detroit Lions
averaged 17.8 points per game against
Mike Zimmer right now the Lions have
beaten the Vikings three out of four
times yeah but they're not getting a lot
of points and I would argue that Kirk
Cousins is the best quarterback that
they've had yeah since this series
really started yeah he's better than
Teddy Bridgewater he's better than Sam
but as they've had since brett farr love
that yeah game flow yeah
Detroit's max people in the first
quarter out scores them by 39 I think
Detroit's gonna get the lead in this
game too I could see that uh-huh the
third quarter Detroit's outscored by 54
points and the Vikings outscore people
by 10 I see this game as a close
hard-fought game I am putting $50
because there's something about these
games that scare me I have Minnesota
winning 26 to 20 men
so de $50 I'm putting them on the
Vikings I hear you I I just I I'm not
one and I wonder this without Golden
Tate you know I think that the Lions I
the Lions and the Broncos both sold a
wide receiver mm-hmm the difference is
with the Lions they I think everyone's
been wanting to see gala day and all
that we're gonna get to the Texans later
they're facing the guy they traded which
i think is fascinating but in this game
I go who's gonna play underneath part of
the reason you're getting the
one-on-ones with Marvin Jones and Koenig
ala days you're afraid of Golden Tate
underneath I'm not afraid of TJ Jones
I'm not afraid of this Michael Robinson
tight end or Michael Roberts tight end
who's been doing well but and I'm and
like carry-ons there but I don't I think
you needed Golden Tate there for the
fear and there's a lot of Detroit things
that I need I need the deep throws I
need that run defense to be where it
needs to be but I think Minnesota comes
in this game at home maybe I should have
done more I'm just afraid of the Lions
three out of four on them but I'm going
$50 on Minnesota all right guys last
game at one o'clock the three and four
Atlanta Falcons on the road visiting
five and to Washington spread in this
game is Washington - one and a half
whether in Landover on Sunday high of 57
sunny low of 45 left go take it away
alright so on before I get to the
injuries Atlanta scoring 27 points per
game yeah they're allowing 30 points per
game yeah Washington's only scoring 21
points per game they're only allowing 19
injuries did not practice Atlanta Matt
Bryant Robert Alford remember they're
coming off a bye to write Washington did
not practice Adrian Peterson Chris
Thompson Jameson Crowder Paul Richardson
Trent Williams I am instantly regretting
my stuff go for it
Washington my gun and we could play but
Adrian this is just did not practice
Wednesday Adrian Peterson Chris Thompson
Jameson Crowder Paul Richardson Trenton
Williams Williams was a thumb and a
shoulder Richardson was a shoulder and a
knee Crowder's an ankle Thompson's a rib
and Peterson is shoulder but he's a
practicing
yes whatever yeah him and Trent Williams
I don't know if they'll ever practicing
on Wednesday ever again in their life so
don't worry about that um okay
the skins are the better team they are I
do feel that for sure I hate the Falcons
D does suck we know that you know your
points though is like you know I know
what you're saying like can the
Washington offense really take advantage
of that you know I I don't have a ton of
faith in that that aspect of the game
totally I'm not gonna sit here and go
well Alex Smith is gonna tear up the
Falcons defense no I don't know about
that the Falcons are desperate there's
no doubt about that you know I also I
guess to a degree you know the Greg
mineski great zone coverages they
concern me a hair verse Elena because
Atlanta has enough of an offense and
weapons and Matt Ryan's good enough to
wear okay you're not gonna fool him a
little like you saw drew Brees do the
Washington Redskins and Washington blew
a few coverages there I'm not trying to
say that altogether but I'm just trying
to say that I do think that there's
chances for them to move the football in
this game as well as yeah I don't think
there's gonna be pressure pressure
issues with Matt Ryan and all that and I
like I said I think the Falcons have the
type of O to beat some of those zone
coverages in general and are good enough
running the ball to where they can keep
you honest it's an interesting football
game the Falcons are desperate the
Redskins are feeling good they're not an
impressive team that wins games in a
pretty fashion but they're battle tested
and they come out on top a lot in these
football games and you know damage you
spend a lot of times in a row it's hard
for me to go against them really so I am
betting $50 in the Washington Redskins
I don't feel necessarily confident about
that any game I go $50 on for the
listeners out there I don't feel totally
confident that's why I'm going 50 I just
go I never go lower than 50 cuz I want
to give some juice to the show but I
picked the score to be 26:23 Washington
Redskins okay so I wanted to see how has
Washington fared against the best
offense as this season allowed 21 in d7
teen in Green Bay 17 to Carolina yeah 43
to New Orleans right I actually have a
theory yeah I didn't the Saints game is
actually helping Washington these last
few games because I feel like everyone's
done and they're like let's do this and
I that was an emotional record-breaking
night that I don't think can be
quantified yes coverage is they haven't
done all year yes
Washington is the highest ranked pass
defense that Atlanta is going to face
this season yet right 13th every team
has scored less than their season
average against Washington except for
New Orleans it's there it's one of their
worst games of the year the other
question I had is Matt Ryan outside yeah
Matt Ryan outside one o'clock games yeah
Atlanta outside this season they faced
Pittsburgh in Philadelphia they scored
29 points combined in those two games
and I don't think Philadelphia and
Pittsburgh's defense I think
Philadelphia's defense is good but
Pittsburgh defense is not that good they
put up 17 Matt Ryan outdoors in one
o'clock games 17 against the Steelers
and a loss last year 17 against Carolina
25 against the Jets in that game that
they were supposed to win by a lot and
barely cover yep barely won bears
23 points in the season opener it was
very reliant on those two tight end
touchdowns and the rest of their offense
suck a whole game zactly Wright 2016 in
their amazing year
remember that Eagles loss yeah one
o'clock road game 15 points I think that
Atlanta outside one o'clock is not a
great game right
also I wondered can Washington pound
Atlanta with Adrian Peterson right five
of their seven games Atlanta has allowed
a hundred and ten yards rushing or more
yeah
Atlanta is Owen five straight up and
against the spread when an underdog
their two and eight against the spread
in road games the interesting thing
about Washington is can they withstand
the second quarter and
fourth-quarter rushes of Atlanta Atlanta
is scoring 77% of their points in the
second quarter and fourth quarter the
thing that I'm scared of the most
is Washington has scored nine points in
third quarters this season I am putting
$200 on washing yeah my score is
Washington 27 to 20 yeah I think it's
Atlanta off of a buy going we're gonna
put up some points I think they're gonna
go on the road 1 o'clock game against
Washington I think ha ha Clinton dicks
please don't make mistakes I think that
I just think it's a tough game and I
think Washington's gonna win this game
and I'm only having it's what 1 and a
half yeah yeah $200 on Alex Smith I know
how's that feel all right I mean it's
it's more of it's more of its I think
that people look at these offenses
sometimes and things that they can
transfer everywhere right and I think
that Atlanta outside is a different team
sure it's not fast you're not gonna get
any push in the middle against this
Washington defense they're gonna be all
over your [ __ ] so I think that the
Atlanta offense is gonna be tough and I
think once it starts coming down to
field position and and I could see this
Adrian Peterson thing keep going or
their defensive lines banged up they
don't have good linebackers their safety
play isn't there yeah Washington wants
to take you back to 1980s and John
Riggins and so I see them just beating
up Atlanta and guess what I think you
could beat up Atlanta that's just how I
see that game yeah I hear you I you know
what scares me that's the only thing
that scares me
all right guys moving on to these
weapons here just scares this scares the
crap out of me I could just see you know
they're like I could see four
opportunities to put the game away and
you go damn it's 20
it's 27 21 and Matt Ryan's got the ball
on the last Drive that's sad at 27 20
yeah I know I hear it sigh I just
couldn't put money on it I check it yeah
I hear you and when I first saw this I
was like
only one and a half two and I know like
Dennis the lead producer for gridiron
Heights is like deathly afraid he's like
we're losing to Atlanta and I just I I I
think this is a good if it was in
Atlanta I'd pick Atlanta yeah I'm just
it's not yeah
all right guys 405 the five and three
Houston Texans on the road visiting the
three and a modern Rothko's spread in
this game is Denver - one whether in
Denver on Sunday it's gonna be partly
cloudy with a high of 53 left go
it is the Demaryius Thomas immediate
revenge game it's amazing
what does that atmosphere gonna be like
they're obviously gonna cheer him yeah I
would say him and Vaughn were and
there's a few other guys but they were
the premier holdovers from their
Superbowl champion right right and he's
coming back to the stadium yeah that's I
mean I gotta think this is like the
first time ever where a guy gets traded
and plays his old old team in the first
week I mean that's good that's crazy
it really is and you know it's gonna be
emotional for Demaryius Thomas it is
it's not gonna be that emotional for the
Broncos they're gonna be oh man sorry
you left but they're not gonna really
put it that way
Denver's yeah it's that's it's gonna be
a fun game I think this is gonna be a
fun game I'm actually Houston has 14
players on their injury reports right
they have ten days though after that
Miami Thursday night win right Zach
Cunningham didn't practice nine players
were listed I've 13 that list a lot of
players ack punt Cunningham hurt do you
know he was his knee yeah Denver did not
practice Roy's Freeman Brandon Marshall
Bradley Roby and Darian Stewart they're
kind of good all right so the first
thing that jumps out to me in this game
when I just go and I'll get this out of
the way - it's tough to play in Denver
let's just not forget that you know and
Denver is battle-tested
Denver's played a pretty tough schedule
oh yeah it's it's hard to deny
I played the Rams the Chiefs twice you
know they played the Baltimore Ravens
okay they played the Seattle Seahawks so
it's not like they've been playing like
you know these just no-name teams that
are just stink I'm gonna give you one of
my nuggets off that yeah that was my
question about the text and today Mile
High Denver held the Rams 223 and the
Chiefs 227 first thing I'm saying is
this Broncos D matches up very well with
this text inside
it does scare you for a lot of reasons
what's the first reason we know like hey
the Texans yes Watson's incredible and
they can make big plays in the past game
but the the Broncos have a good
secondary they can cover people also I
look at what other factor
Watson okay the play making ability damn
it's hard to make plays against this
Bronco defense and run around on them I
mean you know they're they're fast on
the edge you didn't see Patrick mahomes
like run around a whole lot last week
again and do that I know he did it the
first time around but that was amazing
and you know again I know the Shawn
Watson is amazing too but I think it'll
be contained to to a degree um let me
see what else is a I messed up with my
writing here okay
so I guess the other thing I would look
at is you know Broncos run D that's
where I look at Houston and go can they
mash the Broncos up front and control
the game that way to where then they can
make it a one-on-one matchup game
outside you know we can do double moves
with DeAndre Hopkins we can throw our
one-on-one football is there that will
be a big key to the game to me will be
the run game for the Houston Texans and
what they can do there now can the
Broncos move the ball in the Texans I'm
just not sure I don't know about that I
don't trust Case Keenum against this
type of defense that can rush for and be
very chaotic and like we've said they're
there multiple there what's the word I
used yesterday and our film breakdown of
what they do I can't think of the damn
word I was gonna say but you know
they're just they're there they're not
your basic defense they do a lot of
different things and different looks and
you just go damn what is this what's
this front what the hell is this
coverage and that scares me with Case
Keenum who can be a little over
aggressive and throwing the football so
I look at this has been a very close
football game and again a guy like Vance
Joseph is fighting for his football life
here but I got a pick I'm picking the
Texans to win the game okay and I'm
going with the Texans I'm picking I'm
bidding fifty dollars on this but I
don't feel like warm and cozy about it
I'm going $50.00 Texans I think they win
the game 24 to 20 okay
Texans have ten days of rest and the
Broncos just had to chase the Chiefs and
we know how that tires teams out will
the Broncos be able to run on the Texans
I don't think so I think this is the
first game where Phillip Lindsey doesn't
really get it going but if there was a
guy that can get the outside on them it
might be him
yeah sure love Phillip lives sure well
the Texans run all over Denver you bet
your ass I think Lamar Miller and
deshaun Watson that's how they can I
think negate this really good pass rush
of the Broncos sure he's by making them
worry about the run Denver's 27th in the
run yeah I know they do not have a lot
of depth I do not have a lot of big guys
I think that you can pound them my big
question for this game is can of Texans
protect to Shaun Watson yeah
Denver is second the NFL on sacks and
their fifth in sacks per pass attempt so
it even works on that thing right you
were super high on the Texans offensive
line after Thursday and I'm gonna tell
you to self Scout mm-hm
Miami's 30th and sacks so I think it's
very easy to get high on a Texans
offensive line after you play the
Dolphins sure I'm worried about it I
think Watson goes down four or five
times in this line I'm more high on
their run game that just so you know
that but Texans our 26th in allowing sex
per pass attempt right so it's they're
athletic but I know what you mean with
the running yeah my big question for
this is will the Texans allow the big
play yeah Denver is third in 20 plus +
40 + big plays adventures they think
about it yeah Courtland Sutton's Emanuel
Sanders Phillip Lindsey's what gets them
in trouble because case looks for it a
little too much it looks for it all the
time right
but Houston is a team that is allowed
that ninth most 20-plus point 20 plus
yards and the eighth most 40-plus yards
so there are some opportunities there
yeah I don't think Denver can move the
ball down the field against Houston
right but I do think every now and then
you're gonna get a Cortland Sutton shot
and an Emmanuel Sanders shot and I'm
gonna say if you're playing daily
fantasy I'm buying Courtland Sutton I
think so they need to prove that you go
to Courtland Sutton after you lose to
Maris Thomas and he's in the same
building
Courtland Sutton needs to have a hundred
yards receiving for them to look good
right
I look at this game I think Denver's
gonna jump out to a lead early that's
what they've done all season they played
really well against Kansas City they do
not do well in second and third quarters
I think the Texans establish the run
establish a lead and I think they hold
on
Texans 23 Broncos 17 I'm puttin $50 on
the Houston Texans plus one have you
guys agreed on every game so far every
sound every game I think we have there
we go there he stole this [ __ ] formula
for me all right guys next game on
Sunday at 405 the 5 and 2 mo Chargers on
the road visiting the 4 and 3 Seattle
Seahawks spread in this game is Seattle
- - I think this is the most fascinating
game was the week of great weather in
Seattle on Sunday is going to be a high
of 55 low of 46 showers all day left go
what's incredible is the Chargers you
know they put points up twenty seven
point nine points per game this cos are
allowing 18.7 points per game the
thoughts of their demise has been well
exaggerated Joey Bosa still not
practicing for the Chargers DJ Fluker
and KJ right missed practice for the
Seattle Seahawks atcha do you believe
Sims as you start off that the Chargers
can stop the Seahawks running game
because that's my number one question
yeah that will be the one of the keys to
the football game if not the key to the
football game okay so yes the Seattle
Seahawk defense is good I would argue
with that they've only played one good
offense the whole year and they let up
33 points against that team which team
the Rams the Seahawks - yes so I do I
think the stats right are a little
misleading don't get me wrong they're
good they do a lot of good things also
to that side and the other side
the Chargers haven't beaten a good team
the whole year I mean the Chargers are
the most underwhelming win team you've
seen now I know they lost to the Rams
and the Chiefs but they lost by 10 and
12 - both of those teams they beat the
bills the Niners the Raiders the Browns
the Titans okay so those are the things
I look at I'm not sure we know what the
Chargers are yet it's a bye week the Gus
Bradley factor Gus Bradley runs the
Seattle scheme he came from Seattle all
of that I think if I look at that aspect
just go I think the Charger's will have
more tricks up their sleeves on the
offensive side of the ball to screw
Seattle than the other way around
you mentioned the run game thing with
the the Los Angeles chargers I do that's
that's what I worry about I really do um
I do think let me just see where I was
going here with this I don't have
anything like that just goes oh they are
going to win this football game or I
feel great about this
I think the Chargers are gonna move the
ball on Seattle I do that the Chargers
can do everything it's a well rounded
offense they can run the ball they
protect the Prosser well enough and
Rivers is gonna make plays downfield it
is gonna be about the Chargers being
able to stop their run game and I think
with the two weeks off I'm gonna put my
faith and I just have a I think it's the
Chargers year I don't know why I think
they've gained enough confidence they
had the week off they know they got to
stop the Seattle run game that's special
I'm going $50 on the Chargers
[Music]
let go
so you think Seattle's gonna do against
the LA press rush press rush is that
what he said he said no no you said
protect the Prosser Fredrick the
pressure starters are good at protecting
the Prosser I'm picking the Chargers to
win 24 21 just so you know
24:21 yeah all right so can the charger
stop the seahawks running game I don't
know man they just let up a hundred and
sixty-four yards rushing to Tennessee I
know and Tennessee's running games soft
also the thing that scares me
mm-hmm Chargers don't get off the field
on third down 28th and the NFL and third
down percentage thing about the all the
passes the Titans dropped in that game
Sheriff that could have kept going
towards the end of the game sure the
other thing that I worry about is
Chargers after a bye and London last
seven years after a buy the Chargers are
2 and 5 they and that the two wins they
scored 13 points and 21 points so the
games they've won their offense was a
little bit stagnant right Seahawks and
Raiders the two teams that went to
London play to buy both team started
fast their next game so I'm not too
worried about both teams put out like 28
points in the first half like that will
the Seahawks be able to slow down Melvin
Gordon is my fear for Seattle Seattle in
their two home games they haven't played
a lot of home games this year Dallas and
the Rams
those games they've allowed 321 rushing
yards combined Zeke and Todd Gurley got
off so I'm a little bit worried about
Melvin Gordon but Melvin Gordon's a
little bit banged up but he did get the
two weeks of rest yes very interesting
that's I mean that I just yes Chargers
are the number one team in the NFL in
big place number one in 20 plus yards
number one in 40-plus yeah you know as
the number one team defensively in
40-plus Seattle their fifth in 20-plus
so I think the Chargers are a little bit
reliant sometimes and you see it all the
time that deep bass has passes to
Williams the deep passes to both
Williams yeah to Benjamin and to Keenan
Allen the Chargers don't allow the
third-most
20-plus plays
Seattle does like to take shots aptly I
expect more to get his deep shots I
expect Lockett to get his deep shots
yeah can Doug Baldwin and that running
game move it down the field is where I
think it's gonna get interesting I look
at the game flow Chargers outscored
teams in the second quarter so to the
Seahawks both of these teams are second
quarter teams the Seahawks have only
allowed 13 points in the third quarter
all year all year yeah I was leaning
Seahawks and then I saw this stat since
Russell Wilson has started with the
Seahawks against the AFC at home he's 12
and OH hmm why because these teams are
only going to CenturyLink Field once
every eight years it's an experiment
reverse has never played in Seattle
against Russell Wilson hmm like Russell
Wilson's been around for a long time he
has it played there like six years yeah
I am going a hundred dollars on Seattle
I have them winning 27 23 yeah I think
that might have been a peregrine falcon
could have been but I I like Seattle
here I think that the Chargers I think
they're gonna come in here and I the
problem with the Chargers is that I I
know that whenever I see them go down
the field a lot I feel like it ends in
field goals I feel like their points
come most on big plays and Seattle's not
a big play defense and even though they
haven't played that many great offenses
even the Rams at home they should I
couldn't believe they were even in that
game their offense came alive
I like Seattle in this game it's our
first disagreement yeah that's okay this
is a tough one
it really is everything you know I get
it I really just came down to me is just
the Chargers the year I think they are a
different team and I don't know what I
know about Seattle's defense yeah that's
always that's why it's a very fair point
that's the only thing I just wasn't sure
all right guys much why I only think
that I would say though about the Rams
game is I don't know if Gordon's Gurley
no he's not he's not girly but I'm not
so sure oh yeah yeah he's not you're
right I mean he's not girly but
you still really damned yeah yeah that's
a good one I'm glad we disagree that's
come on you I think it's gonna be one of
the fun games that I had fifty on it and
I upped it to a hundred right and I took
fifty away from a game that we're gonna
do in a few seconds not the next one
all right guys for twenty five on Sunday
the LA Rams at eight no on the road
visiting the six and one New Orleans
Saints card in this game is New Orleans
minus one weather in New Orleans on
Sunday just in case you're curious
thunderstorms in the afternoon high of
78 left go
so the Rams Cooper Cup is back limited
in practice and as we know Marcus
Davenport is out that's things Rams
scoring 33 points a game and only
allowing nineteen point four point zero
four it seems yeah I mean I look at that
you got the number one run offense in
football versus the number one run
defense in football in the New Orleans
Saints you know that's to me where I
look at one part of the game and just go
that's intriguing I do think that the
Rams regardless of their success in the
run game just have to continue to run
you get to run the ball the Rams are
gonna be able to throw on this the
Saints defense I just would be
absolutely shocked Minnesota yeah I just
look today I'm absolutely shocked
I really would be and this is a much
more well rounded offense with the Rams
than it is Minnesota are we sure this
lines right yes why you're seeing
something else I mean it started off as
Rams minus one I don't I don't know how
it got to I have it as New Orleans minus
one in our casino we use okay so but we
got a New Orleans - one and a half yeah
it's it's as high as two in some places
alright
yeah so okay so I guess that bad aspect
hey I think the Rams are gonna be able
to throw the ball on the Saints I do
think it's gonna be tough on this Rams
offense down there in New Orleans it's a
loud place it really is I played there
I've been there
it's gonna be tough to communicate
things at the line of scrimmage but I
don't think the Rams are overly reliant
on that type of play as is I look at the
other side of the ball and hey we know
this Rams defense it's got players we
know that but damn this'll be this is
the best offensive line they've played
all year what's that you're good I'm
just looking at left how this is the
best offensive line they've played all
year I have a hard time thinking that
one Sean Payton
drew brees are gonna let Aaron Donald
ensue get off they're gonna be smart
about especially early just get the
bottom our hands let's do some
misdirection let's do this let's do that
and if there's a weakness to the Rams
defense it's still to run defense I know
it's better this year and whatever else
but this is a special offensive line
with the New Orleans Saints and it's a
downhill offensive line and there is
seems to be had with how the Rams play
defense and Aaron Donald's is awesome as
he is
nobody's perfect in football okay
everybody he will let up some lanes in
the run game because he flies so quickly
upfield at times that you just replace
them and then I'll you go Dan there's 20
yards you know they have a size
advantage there on the front so that's
going to be extremely interesting as
well and I look at it morale not at the
end of the day with the New Orleans
Saints being at home I don't think the
Rams have played in this type of game
quite yet and are experienced on the
road like this before and because of
that I'm going $50 on the Saints I think
it's gonna be extremely close game
I don't feel totally comfortable about
it I do worry about the Saints secondary
getting shredded apart
I do think Eli Apple's gonna help this
team though I do I think you saw out of
them III yes and I think he was having a
good year before this and I also like
Chris Collins were said the night before
he's got a great support system
he's got the whole secondary from Ohio
State it's Lattimore it's Vaughn Bell
it's Kirk Coleman it's it's unbelievable
I'm missing somebody else too so the
Saints are the Ohio State to
Washington's Alabama yeah you pretty
much it's it's worked out that way so I
look at that and yet that's why I'm just
going with the RAM the Saints to win a
field gold type game but I'm going
what's your score 32 27 30 or 27 yeah I
think the Rams are gonna pass all over
the Saints as you said Saints defense
not great with sacks awful with third
down percentage awful in the red zone
yeah can the Rams slow down the Saints
rushing attack Rams are 12th in the NFL
and rush defense I was very surprised to
see the Saints
have the number one rush defense in the
NFL why I think it's because everyone's
throwing on the Saints I mean I don't
know if I yeah I mean there's definitely
that definitely I mean there's no doubt
about that they are choosing to throw
the football on them yes there but they
got some dude dude they got three first
rounders in their front lines right now
they're down to two but yeah they're big
the same stopping line back the Saints
have led up a ton of points in second
quarters this year right and the Rams
are out scoring teams by damn near 50 in
the second quarter
yeah the Rams are out scoring teams in
the second and third quarter by 80
points this year that's when they pull
away from you and then you try and do
things at the end I am going $200 on the
Rams I have this catered um as bed of
the day I have this game 33 to 30 Rams
the way I look at it is this the Rams on
a fast track against the Saints right I
understand what you're saying about the
offensive line being big sure I think
that you can be big all you want Aaron
Donald's gonna get through eventually
then I don't think I think that the
Saints are gonna try and match the Rams
speed that's the question is that my
question that's the question I wrote
here in Boulder is will the Rams set the
pace or will the Saints slow the guy
down that's my big question yeah and I
think the Rams are gonna jump out early
okay and I think what's gonna happen is
this is just my guess yeah I think the
Rams jump out early and the Saints don't
complete some third downs and I think
Shawn paint's gonna go for it I think
this is the game where they don't happen
yeah I think that Sean Payton is gonna
look at across the line and go holy [ __ ]
Sean McVeigh might be a better coach
than me I think that's what we're gonna
see this week I think this is the oh
[ __ ] Rams game I think the Saints last
week what I can't get out of my head is
what the Vikings offense was doing to
them and now they lost their best pass
rusher and that's why I have fear for
them because I know that Jared Goff is
not as good as Sean McVeigh but I think
that Gurley on this field it could be
special I know that you're looking right
now in your super except Thomas better
your day dumb
that go ahead good I'm glad yeah good
idea waiting weather though the fact
that I'm getting the Rams right plus
points I mean the Rams all the big plays
they let up on defense holy cow I mean
there's people gonna be open everywhere
all I need is a Rams win and I think the
Rams are gonna win this game that was
one go like you think the Saints are
gonna win yes and I think the Rams are
gonna win yeah and you need to win by a
point and a half and I just want them to
win yeah and I think that of the two
teams the Rams are more built to get
into a shootout whereas I feel like the
Saints are more built to control the
flow of the game and I don't think the
Rams are gonna let them control the flow
of the game okay that's what I think and
I know that you're sitting there going
you you think that you know totally no I
don't know it at all that's why I went
$50 you're acting like you know it and
you're all these theories on McVerry is
gonna look like he's the coach now and
Sean Payton's gonna go oh my gosh I'm
not as good anymore like that no I think
I think what's gonna be interesting is
Sean Payton I feel like has had the
shamrock ax
the Saints have had the shamrock up up
their ass for a few games now the
Minnesota game and then they tore apart
Washington and I think that was I don't
wanna say it was a fluke but I don't
think that's gonna happen again
and yeah I mean you're not making me
feel that confident right now
Wow it's a listen this is a coin toss
football game and you think the Rams are
better I don't if there's anything wrong
with that at all
yeah I don't think there's anything
wrong with that I just think that Jared
Goff is gonna have time yeah he might he
might he might have time and I don't
think Sean I don't think I think that
when push comes to shove Drew Brees is
gonna go man
[ __ ] Aaron Donald didn't get in here
for two and a half quarters but holy
crap they're up by 10 and he's in my
face almost every play sure and the
other thing is that no one's talking
about the Saints who's their number
three wide receiver right now yeah
that's that loss a Ted Ginn was I think
one of the biggest losses of the year
sure and no one's talking about it yeah
and I don't know yeah listen it's a coin
toss football game I'm just going with a
team that I know is battle-tested tough
and there at home that's the only reason
I did
all right guys Sunday Night Football the
three three and one Green Bay Packers on
the road visiting the six and two New
England Patriots spread in this game New
England minus five and a half Foxborough
going to be in
I stay on our nice night on Sunday
excuse me 53 is the high mostly sunny
let go
Edelman and check Mason miss practice on
Wednesday Nick Perry miss practice for
the Packers what's what's Shaq Mason
calf calf damn I was wondering why he
was out of the game Marcus Cannon missed
the game on Monday right so that'll be
interesting okay so let's start to start
it here I mean this is gonna be an
awesome game I don't know what else to
say New England's defense is certainly
nothing special I understand that this
is the type of game if Rogers can really
run around he could dominate the game I
mean he can make plays just by himself
there's no great pass rushers or edge
speed he can find the ways to dance in
the pocket and eventually find the
people that are wide open down the field
I also look at you know okay it does
scare me that you know again the I think
the Patriots gonna take away Davante
Adams and a lot of crucial situations
you're not gonna get slanting goes to
him on third down or any big place to
him I think that's all they're bright
lights will be on him you know do do the
Packers try to stay patient with the run
game to a degree that would be something
I would look forward to look forward to
you know I would like to I think they
got away with it a little bit last week
if they can do that this could be very
interesting because it's just an element
of the Packers offense it's very
inconsistent and it is a little bit of a
weakness for the Patriots in general I
think on the other side of the ball you
know no Sony Michelle no run game it's
just not as impressive a run game
without Stoney Michele he's a really
good running back now they'll find ways
to continue to do that but the Patriots
are a little bit different than years
past they want to kind of be 50/50 they
really do they're trying to play that
style of football they're not trying to
dice you up in the pass game Gronk is
not quite the same
Edelman looked as good as I've seen him
look last week as I've looked all year
so that's interesting to me too but this
Packers D I think is going to be able to
cover New England in the pass game in
general but still you know there's
familiarity with the Mike Pettine
defense in New England because of the
years of the New York Jets I
that into account and I just think the
Patriots are a better football team but
I'm putting $100 on the Green Bay
Packers I just don't think they're gonna
win by more than six points I like the
Revolution better Nick you're the
Revolution is better oh wait that was go
pack go what the hell my yeah I didn't
even sound like go pack go it's I'm
cooking pack I know but they go denden
dented and and don't go pack Oh
so Patriots 31 Packers 28 Wow all right
so will the Patriots get to Aaron
Rodgers or slow them down
Patriots only have 12 sacks this season
and their 27th in passing defense so I
think Aaron Rodgers gonna put up some
yards yeah I also think the weakest part
of the Packers Dean correct me if I'm
wrong is their linebackers and and so
when you're playing a team that has
Edelman and white and all of those guys
the Patriots are going to move the ball
wherever they want the thing that I get
really afraid about is the Patriots
could jump out to a huge lead yeah the
Packers are being outscored in the first
half by teams by 35 points the Patriots
are out scoring teams in the second
quarter by 56 points they have they have
scored 92 points and second quarters
thus far this season right so I think
the Patriots are gonna jump out to an
early lead I have the Patriots winning
this game 31 to 27 and I am putting $50
on Green Bay
[Applause]
if I know that guitar there I took $50
away from Green Bay and I put it on
Seattle got you because I like the
Seattle matchup with the Chargers more
right
I am afraid that the the Packers I could
see it I have it 3127 I could see it
ending 31 21 of those touchdowns at the
end I think that I think it's gonna be
an Aaron Rodgers trying to make a
comeback
that's how I see the flow of this game I
I blew say I think they match up very
good in New England
yeah but I see New England jumping out
to like a 21 to 10 lead yeah I'm then
you know I don't I don't know I don't I
don't play that game in my head I don't
play I know I do I know you do that's
why I go watches the whole game so then
that's sorry that's cool I just I you
know to me one of the big things I went
with here is the Packers run defense is
an issue it is an issue and I don't know
if the Patriots can run consistently on
them right now with kind of the state of
their own line and all that and know
Sony Michelle
so that scared me I really think I could
see the Packers are gonna be [ __ ]
desperate in this game Packers are
Packers lose this they're gonna have to
like start running the table here they
have no wiggle room they're gonna be in
trouble I'm not saying that to run the
table but they're gonna have to be damn
good down the stretch this is a huge
game for the Packer I believe I watched
Patriots bills on Monday and went may
have to Bills had an offense the Patriot
I'd be in trouble
yeah all right guys last game of the
weekend here three and four Tennessee on
the road visiting for Dallas no okay
spread in this game is Dallas minus six
it opened at Dallas - force and weather
in Dallas on Monday night 76 degrees all
right
there's no injuries but I'm gonna lead
this one if you're yeah go ahead please
Titans are averaging 15 points a game
yeah and they're allowing 18 Cowboys are
scoring 20 and allowing 17 these are
some of the lowest scoring teams in the
NFL yeah
can the Titans stop Zeek the run defense
is 19th they only have 15 sacks 27th in
the NFL so I think Dax gonna have some
time back there right Dallas defense
here we go baby
9th and run third and pass they got
everybody all
they're crazy dogs are healthy they've
had a bye week I don't think anyone
needed a bye week more than Dallas yeah
get that defense line up to speed
get that offensive line as healthy a
healthy as they can
Tennessee is the number one team in the
NFL in red zone defense which is
interesting yeah Dallas I don't need
them settling for field goals here
here's the thing man
Tennessee has only scored six points all
season in the second quarter Keith
they've only scored 17 points all season
in the third quarter I think Dallas
builds a lead in that area
Dallas has only allowed 30 points all
year in quarters one in three combined
that's how good Dallas defense has been
right I have $100 on Dallas and I have
them winning this game 22:13 by the
third game I want to say this though
Tennessee since they came around or
since Oh eight there six now against the
spread on Monday Night Football hmm but
I don't play that [ __ ] game it
doesn't matter I wanted to go last week
13 Cowboys yeah it's gonna be an ugly
football game I have no faith in the
Dallas Cowboys and moving the ball
really on the Tennessee Titans Amari
Cooper's got a real tough matchup right
away yeah I mean that you know the run
game defense like you talked about it is
an issue right like with the Tennessee
Titans it's not great but the only thing
I'll say it's the Dallas Cowboys I mean
there's not a more boring offensive
scheme in football maybe then Green Bay
and Aaron Rodgers so you know that as
far as just like what I see on a weekly
basis and I think Tennessee will be able
to match up with them man-to-man be able
to put people in the Box top the thing
so slow down the run game from that
aspect Tennessee offense man it's
underwhelming as well it stinks it's
donkey crap okay I can tell you that
much but I also would say you know the
way the offense played going the by I
got to think that Vrabel like took
Lafleur into a room cornered him and put
him in a chokehold and said if you don't
come up with some more F in plays I'm
gonna whoop your ass okay not really I'm
just being funny but I got to think that
there's something there that Lafleur
didn't realizes like damn I could be a
one-and-done guy with the way this
offense looks right now and he's going
to have to do
something different either way it's in
Dallas
I trust Dallas more their defense is
better I'm gonna trust that they fired
their offensive line coach and that they
got something better up their sleeve
they're a little bit - I'm putting a
hundred dollars on the Tennessee Titans
Wow but I think it's gonna be but I'm
picking Dallas to win the game 19 to 16
I can't pick Dallas to beat like you
know any team by more than six points
right now I just don't trust that so
that's why I did it this is the Zeke
explosion game think so I think this is
the Zeke 185 yards rushing one touchdown
the ground 65 in the air with a
touchdown the air gosh if that happens
against Mike Vrabel and Dean piece and I
I will I just I just and I would be
shocked all right guys so this week only
three disagreements all in the later
games you guys disagree on LA and
Seattle Sims you're going with the
Chargers left going left go going with
the Seahawks Russell Wilson at home Sims
going with the Saints left go going with
the Rams and left goes got 200 bleacher
bucks on the Rams and then Monday Night
Football Sims going with Tennessee left
go going with Dallas who are you
thinking about locking so I definitely
think I'm gonna lock the Chiefs
- eight against the Browns yeah I think
I'm gonna lock the Steelers plus three
in Baltimore I like that matchup okay I
think I'm gonna lock Washington - one
and a half against Atlanta yeah and now
I'm debating you've scared me off of
Rams oh yeah don't listen to me man but
beat me in this like [ __ ] every what I'm
thinking about going Seattle - two
against the Chargers but I don't I mean
that's not great the problem is is I
don't like the ten for Chicago it's too
much I am NOT gonna I'm not gonna bet on
the Jets down there in Miami I have no
idea what I like if you just main ask me
fer I know why I chickened out a little
bit the Green Bay one is one where I
look at it and go I think I chickened
out a little what do you mean I just
think that I have a hard time thinking
they're gonna lose this game by more
than six I really do I'm happy to do it
I mean I bet I don't want I don't want
to sway you there
but then I can put guilt on you I know
you can hey guys we got to wrap up the
show but there's one thing we haven't
done yet all right hold on that I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna go with the Sims
pic and I'm going Green Bay plus six and
a half I don't think they'll win I don't
need in the wind I'm right just so you
know I got six
that's fine I'll take six I am rooting
for them to win all right just do you
know these are the ones with the
checkmarks okay cuz I wrote a few down I
had my first three but after that it got
hard I was like damn I don't know which
ones to do here so it's just the ones
with the checkmarks all right all right
did you not like that no matter what our
pics are and how much money we wager
there's one place that you should
actually put your money and it's money
line time baby it is guaranteed to lose
the Sims fiery five ten and oh the last
two weeks 14 and one the last three
weeks twenty two and three the last five
week heavy hitter guaranteed to lose
it's serious but the music's not and we
start off first in Buffalo of course we
did do you know their quarterback is yes
is they the meter man how the hell can
they win and bears like to eat Buffalo
so they win sorry Buffalo you lose I
don't know if they actually eat them but
it sounded good speaking of former
backup quarterbacks let's go to Carolina
Oh Fitz magic no this shall be tragic
there's no way you're beating Carolina
in Carolina could be close could be fun
he might tease us
but it's Cam Newton and they gonna win
what happens when the hottest team in
the NFL takes on a team that just fired
their head coach at offensive
coordinator sounds a lose-lose
lose hello Cleveland I don't believe
Lynde you're not gonna get back on the
winning ways this week not against
Kansas City no how no way
Sharon Lefko said so after an article
was written
slamming the quarterback of Minnesota
you're pretty sure there were what in
this game I am I think the better team
sorry Detroit you're gonna lose this
week you know why because Minnesota's
better that's why and I'm the Oracle and
I say so sorry Detroit and in the
matchup featuring two of the greatest
quarterbacks of all time Sims is ready
to make a super stamp I'm making a super
stamp and I'm kind of wishing I'm wrong
on this one I don't know I'm think I'm
using reverse psychology
to change the carnival of the earth but
Green Bay sorry I just can't pick you to
win in New England
that's the Patriots and they're better
and I don't know what else to say but
davon room for you and Rodgers and there
we go Sims are speaking against the
bills the Bucs
the Browns the Patriots and the Lions
today's guaranteed to lose was brought
to you by these tumblers Josh bottom
don't know what they're called
they're great all right I'm really
nervous about - you're guaranteed to
loses I am - I couldn't figure out the
last two you that's right I mean I came
down to do I want to pick the Falcons do
I want to pick the Broncos to lose to
the Texans
I just couldn't do it I don't know why I
don't have the power I built I just
couldn't do it for Sims he's that all me
the Hendrick would say good evening
everybody lef koe ma'am says Sims get
the hell out of here